[Music]
[Music]
the junta shouldn't do this and it
should not happen this is like the junta
officially challenging the public this
act will make people wake up and become
interested in politics again our people
should not just be mourning on social
media but also acting individually to do
what they can to speed up the fight
against the junta and we will take
revenge
[Music]
[Music]
we need to get a real democracy because
the real democratic government will
bring the brighter future of our young
generation
that's why we keep on pushing
[Music]
they are now executing political
prisoners that's clearly what these
people were
and uh you know this is on top of the
crimes against humanity that have been
committed by military forces all across
the country against civilians
uh it is astonishing that the
international community has been sitting
back and just twiddling their thumbs
as myanmar has descended into this
horrible situation of
absolute human rights abuses occurring
across the country
[Music]
[Music]
you